coming from I come from you know you
longer gosh the money he doesn't give
you your money you got it you have to
seek retribution other types away so I
feel like they should just go out there
and line up the faith and see what it do
you know since its line up to fade and
oh you matter sighs Oh matter just line
it up and they squabble it out maybe
let's line up a fight we videotape it we
put it on YouTube with charging
percentage and he can make nine attack
that way link you know what you are
you're an idea man what do you think of
this I don't know if as judge I can do
this but maybe I can look it up in one
of these books uh what if I went in
there and told them that that you know
just for old times sake they should get
drunk one more time and then when the
defendant is drunk the plaintiff can say
hey can you owe me $9 because I bet you
he'd give him the $900 while he's drunk
hmm or maybe the defendant cash was $900
again and get it from the plaintiff and
pay him back the first night I know if
he's too drunk he sees my exact yeah I
bleed win football guy that big guy
seems like he can handle his booze nah
that guy that guy softest cotton bro you
think I know it I think he drinks a nice
warm well I think he drinks a nice cold
glass of Chablis and he's shit-faced
that's a lot of little girl hangs out
with him so you can't you can't really
just measure a person's size like that
you know I'm not much of a drinker
myself I have a couple of them and next
thing I know I got some buxom hundred
and an 80 pound blonde you know crawling
about my body I got a terrible horrible
yeah it was big Eastern European stick
once you don't time off they always did
I was applying you like a three slinky
and I let him see that I love it
people might call you slinky kinky
slinky with the stinky pinky but that
was in my high school days
they shook hands with us stinky pinky
they got hand sanitizer in the dressing
room I mom right I can come in and
infect you you know I'm saying cuz you
is a white man in the role and you might
be very sluggish my future you know so
far I hope I am responsible for your
future because you're in charge